hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and the air quality's bad
hmm I'm John Humphrey I just mostly
wanted to plug our friends before DX for
this andy dandy face mask that's awesome
thanks John
anytime 4dx all the way we're gonna
watch this video from Vanity Fair Joker
director Todd Phillips believes that
comedy breaks down the opening scene
breaks down the death of comin pretty
expand the opening scene of Joker here's
a topper watch a video request from a
man named Niraj Krishna Niraj has been a
longtime subscriber longtime patronage
act and he has finally reached top
reward tier status at our patreon page
appreciate that Niraj guys have seen her
Joker non-spoiler review or spoiler talk
he'll watch that I was on movie fights I
pitched oh who's my favorite Joker check
that round out also pitch my idea for
what you can do for a joke or two it's
just a great panel overall I think you
would really like it hi I'm Todd
Phillips director of Joker and today
we're going to do a couple scene
breakdown from the opening
[Music]
okay we'll just skip all the other
letters
the main job of a director even all this
stuff we talk about cameras and depth of
field and sets and wardrobe and I think
really what a director is is a purveyor
of tone and I think the thing I'm most
proud about are that several times is
that unsettling tone that sort of slow
ramp-up into insanity so I always obsess
over opening shots of movies my movies i
watch I think it's it's a great way it's
a great storytelling device the very
opening of the film yes we have the
benefit in this scene of the local news
playing underneath it and we meet Arthur
there alone at the mirror as he's
putting on his makeup so this scene was
shot pretty early in our schedule and
it's a practical location meaning it's
not a build we're in a real second floor
storage facility up in Harlem on the far
west side of Manhattan there's a
beautiful space with this very sparse
view of the underside of the West Side
Highway this sort of structure that
holds it the west side of Highways these
things were seeing out the window there
and we thought it was a great place for
haha' which represents the agency that
kind of rents out clowns and strippers
and magicians and it's where Arthur were
strippers
everything in the movie is meant to be
unsettling so anytime we kind of moved
the camera intentionally like this it
was always to give off this kind of
unsettling vibe of this guy who's pretty
much separated from everybody else even
in this locker room space you hear the
voices of four or five guys over here
playing cards and talking about whatever
and Arthur's here alone not part of the
group figuring out how they keep a smile
on his face you know one of the themes
in the film just smile and the the idea
of putting on a happy face his mother
told him that he was born to bring joy
and laughter into the world and is
something that Arthur wrestles with
throughout the movie so in this scene we
find him as he's literally pulling up
his mouth and putting down his mouth
sort of fighting the comedy tragedy that
is his life I was really important to me
and Lawrence share my cinematographer
then we have a handmade feel we wanted
it to feel we thought that would lend
itself to the intimacy that we're trying
to get with this character study of
Arthur so you'll see in this scene you
can feel there's an operator there and
that's all really intentionally Mel
soaking up these kind of extreme
close-ups
that by the way right there that tear
just happened and one take walking is a
really interesting process it's not as a
lot of people always assume walking
would be lost in the part the beautiful
thing about Joaquin is we we were
shooting this movie we spent half the
time just laughing offset having a good
time but he's so amazing that they were
then sit down action gets called and we
do this slow pushing and if I think I
remember it right in this particular
scene I was playing the score for him in
the room because that's what he'll do
good Anita was a composer I had her
write music before we shot the movie
which isn't done very often and um she
wrote it based on the screenplay and I
wanted that the reason I wanna that's so
brilliant and in fact this really kind
of even camera operators the set
dressers the word damn that music better
again but freaking Amon a smile and his
friend figuring out again if his life is
a comedy or a tragedy this little tear
appears and we just had the scene
[Music]
we called this set Gotham Square and
this is sort of our version of Times
Square the busy kind of market of Gotham
in 1981 and this is interesting because
we shot this in Newark or Jersey and
here's our if they're down there this
little clown in this big imposing world
I would say pretty much everything from
here back here is CG world building my
real stuff is what you see here in the
foreground we put up you know things
like that you know we built this theater
changed into a porn theater of this time
inspector yeah all this deep background
stuff even those cars and the buildings
that's all put in later and post I
always think this job is particularly
beautiful and helps him just setting the
stage of Arthur's world
[Music]
and this is really where Arthur is at
home he's got a mask on he's pretending
to be somebody else and he gets lost in
his work it's also where we learned that
Arthur has music in him something I
conveyed to what Kings that Arthur is a
guy that has music in his soul and that
will continue when he transforms into
Joker and this is one of the neural
representations of him having that music
I can probably practiced with this sign
for about two or three days it was more
complicated than it looks running in
these giant clown shoes like every movie
you know we spoke a lot about every
element of the movie and Mark Burgess
who's a fantastic costume designer
designed all the Wardrobe in the movie
and we spoke about this particular
outfit for Arthur a lot and also these
shoes and how big and these shoes be
ready to run through the streets of cop
doesn't wandering that darkness sign be
for him to actually pull off being able
to do this like one of those sign guys
you see on the street and his costume is
inspired a little bit by Charlie Chaplin
there's grace Arthur that if you would
just let go and take off the mask he
could even find and that's kind of what
happens when he becomes Joker ironically
it's Arthur taking off the mask even
though he's putting on my big white face
painting a dying his hair
what are the complicated things about
doing period film is actually all these
picture cars all these cars have to be
of the time and basically take over this
whole Street in Newark so this is what I
mean this is a big shot actually with a
ton of real practical picture cars it
goes pretty deep but again I would say
all that is CG back there its world
building a lot of our visual references
were movies that were late seventies
early eighties films Larry Knight really
chose to shoot a ton of this really long
legs so you have a little shallow depth
of field a scene some of those old
school movies so something which is a
perfect example of how blurry everything
is back here in the background and
really only focuses 1 2 3 4 but guys you
really want focus blurry and that's one
of those things that those old films
they basically steal shots and on live
stream about that connection you know
the cameras over here and they're just
following a coloring ended up coming and
we try to get it that look and it gives
it crystal
working is a great stunt double name
steve is you come easy and is he did all
the walking's kind of near misses and
[Music]
again this is all live done by mark
freiburg except weirdly because I'm
obsessive and they like the blank space
so this building's back here that's all
put in because I wanted it to feel
really oppressive and Gotham is always
over Arthur and we just didn't love any
kind of blank spaces in the skyline so
to speak that's from right you never
really know somebody until you see them
wrong and there's the thing about Arthur
running in the opening that really the
way walking runs cuz 99% of this running
is art they're the only thing really
that is he did there was that slip and
it's funny because when we tried takes
with Izzy running it just never worked
because he just didn't have Arthur's run
Joaquin is so specific in the way
Arthur's run looked I thought it was
really something so the slide which is
tough to do and impossible for what came
to pulled off is he came in and did but
everything else is really walking
this shot is very particular because
Larry and I felt early on and we don't
do this a lot in the movie we wanted the
frame to feel out of a graphic novel you
don't do this framing a ton but this
felt like a frame of any kind of graphic
novel you know you would read and it's
it's not a normal necessarily movie
angle to me it feels very graphic novel
I was important chop for us to get
[Music]
so this is one of my favorite shots in
the whole movie and it obviously depicts
his loneliness and his pain but really
the important part of this job so first
he's trying to reach for the sign like
maybe I can still fix this many rolls
over and he pushes that little button
and the water comes out of the flower
because what we're saying there with the
water coming out of the flower flower is
he's still Joker he's still there to
make people laugh he's still seeing
comedy in this moment of film and then
film them out and put them back onto the
digital negative you see this little
believe you get on the edges of the
letters and though do you see the grain
of the letters as the film moves you see
the grain because again we wanted this
movie to feel like it could have come
out in the summer of 1979 so little
details like that like going back and
shooting it on an animation stand the
way they shot film titles in the old
days was really important to us and all
the titles we found out that way
what silence is so nuanced so as he
shifts from Arthur to Joker it's not
like I can walk into a phone booth and
it comes out he's Superman this is
something that happens over two hours
and when Yuri watch the film I think
he'd really get an appreciation for the
work that Joaquin did to slowly turn
that dial up the whole movie and I just
tried to match it without directing
style so Joker is that sort of wild
stallion running without a rider did
Hugh Laurie's a great director
he's here's man she left house a long
time ago I still don't understand though
why John wick can kill so many people
but yeah the violence of his movies
carissa that tough poses develop these
like weird multiple images over the
course of this promotional endeavor
first it was like kid Todd Phillips the
guy who did the hangover really make
that
and then it turned into oh this movie is
really impactful didn't know Todd
Phillips had a gate and what a great
director to Todd Phillips shut up and
stop talking about them yes what the
press cycle does movies like these I
gotta say like this level of a tick ulis
direction and that he had for like the
littlest of nuggets
when Arthur's running and then they had
that building that he said was he didn't
like the blank background for that one
he wanted it to feel like Gotham's
always brag Valerie oh yeah yeah yeah
because you kept saying the word
unsettling for like a large chunk of it
I'm like was that the one word you had
on yeah lucky mockingly we make this
more musicans I mean it makes sense to
me why the music is so damn good and
shines so much
I find the relationship between film and
composer I've always thought that was an
interesting thing because a lot of times
do they do the film first and then they
have visuals to at least work off of
yeah and the film's not fully edited or
something
I remember hearing about how the seem
after Arthur shoots the guys in the
subway that the dance scene in the
bathroom they came up with that day
there's also this hole as I seen where
he takes off the makeup I don't know if
he had to go he was taking off to make
it mean all kind of panicky he's doing
more extensional saying like an hour
just trying to figure it out and then
he's like oh my compose I think he said
that composer had a piece of music and
then he just sort of dancing to it you
know just dancing that's the scene right
there I think that's cool how
collaborative Todd Phillips was through
this whole thing it's like just from the
way he's talking about everything and
even remembering like the stunt doubles
name and you know a lot of times these
directors forget people's names in and
it's common especially for even this is
one of the smaller budgeted comic book
films it's still a pretty big movie and
he's a high-profile project for sure I'm
sure ya did not have a lot of chill time
to just hang out yeah and he managed to
still keep all the weight off look how
skinny he gained a bunch of weight by
this point yeah he's still running a lot
the way how he they composed the music
first based off of the script he let
that kind of guide his direction I think
that is so cool in it and also makes a
lot more sense as to why I think the
music really
because there's plenty of movies that
when you've isolate the songs you go you
know this is actually a really great
piece of music Joker in particular the
music truly stood out and I think it's
because of the symmetry of having it
composed for it's kind of like when you
know Tarantino wrote a scene to a
soundtrack and that's why the soundtrack
sounds out so much I think that's why
this originally composed tunes really
stood out yes because of what he said
part of the formation of the movie part
of the pre or production phase you know
which is yeah fascinating it seems like
there was a lot of just really a live
approach going on in the movie and I
feel bad for Todd Phillips in a way
because I've done my best as these
things happen to remind myself that
these people are being asked constantly
these people are contractually obligated
to go out on these press junkets and
answer questions all day something like
this brought it back to the craft in a
way that I thought was really enchanting
and really just worthwhile especially
for a movie like this because you know
there was that narrative like can they
hang over a guy dude the Joker but I
heard that and like yeah he's an odd
choice but at the same time the hangover
is a more cinematic comedy than a lot of
comedies and so in that way you know I
never have really questioned his
abilities as like a filmmaker who maybe
had some tricks up his sleeve and I
really appreciated how thoughtful it
made me appreciate the whole like
everything he had to comment about made
me appreciate it more you know well what
he said about the run and then he
referenced Starsky and Hutch hmm
suddenly made me go wait a minute this
makes a whole lot more sense now how he
was able to do that because Starsky and
Hutch I think is a highly underrated cop
yeah I loved that film
I forget Todd Phillips made that movie
it's like when you if you ask me who
made it I'll remember but I usually I
just found out before we started watch
really I didn't really ever name always
comes to mind if you asked me but then I
I never for some reason when I hear Todd
Phillips I don't ever have Starsky and
Hutch pop up in my brain but he brought
a 1970s type of cop buddy movie to life
it wasn't just let's make fun oh that's
a movie like right Phillies style it's
like yeah let's be cheeky about it but
let's actually kind of do with 70s I
think that's what was so cool about that
film was he really brought it to life
but with a sense of self-awareness to it
so there's none of that like cheekiness
that's in Joker
he really wants you to feel like you're
watching that kind of movie from the era
still the ability to bring it to life
was talking about how you know I'm like
looking at Ben Stiller's run in that
movie and he feels like he really knows
a character based off of how they run
that right there shows you that
sensibility for the auteur the Todd
Phillips is becoming yeah and those
kinds of instincts that truly make a
perceptive and a discerning director
because those are things that you truly
do need and I think that it's easy to
look at a lot of comedies and especially
go well these aren't as much about
filmmaking aesthetics and whatnot but I
don't know I feel like yeah he's taking
kind of everything up over his career
and there's always that comparison of
comedy and horror very similar it's cuz
the biggest movies hangover and that's
an old school yeah and Lovells yeah
Eurotrip for road trip what kind of hero
do you call frat boy humor that's the
phrase I hear associate a lot with this
kind of movies and I think his movies
are above that but I think especially
Starsky and Hutch elevated above oh yeah
I've always liked I've always kind of
had a soft spot in my heart for that
movie there's me yeah I loved what he
had to say about the tangibility and the
little detail like even shooting the
titles the way they would have instead
of just superimposing them and stuff and
I really liked that he bothered to point
out here's where the CGI is here's what
we did with the picture cars like he
really does address a lot of different
facets of the opening sequence and not
just here's what I wanted out of this
shot or yes what I wanted from Joaquin
here and I thought he really did also a
great job of spreading around the credit
and sort of making this feel very
collaborative yeah it's weird you don't
necessarily think of Todd Phillips as it
got to be like respect for your
direction but especially I think too
about purveyor of tone like he had some
things to say where I was like yeah this
guy seems like beyond the comedies we've
come to know him for and especially
since Joker I'm like this guy it seems
very capable of making some interesting
material
yeah as much credit goes to walking in
Phoenix for bringing that to life but I
love how much credit he gave to him in
terms of crafting the movie and trust
not just Oh walking Phoenix really
delivered and he was really emotional I
call those we got what we needed from
him it was sort of like we wanted to
capture this this build
was me yeah it was a Keurig the
craftsmanship of the story they wanted
to tell about who want this to build and
then he was talking about walking and
really leant that awareness he lets
everyone in on the role of being one of
the storytellers I'm sure most directors
that's probably what they do
subconsciously or something I just it's
rare when you actually hear them talk
about it in a way where you're like no
it seems like his team is very integral
in making this happen and there's
something that feels special about that
because especially nowadays and this
isn't to slag off any number of highly
polished movies but you mean like those
theme park movies that's right not
emotional experiences whatsoever I do
gotta say that not every movie even
feels specifically tangible like people
put it together in like a very physical
alive piece of cinema and I feel like
Joker is a movie that achieves that yeah
not to say that it's the only way to be
great but there is a uniquely
handcrafted quality this film feels like
it has and and that was sort of
exemplified just by this little feature
right here I think like the way he was
so precise with his cinematographer or
the kind of moments of framing of when
to keep it hand as I think the handheld
thing I think there was a time where it
was just kind of annoying because what
is you're using it yeah it's just a
means to create intensity is like a
gimmick this does have an intimate vibe
to it but a lot of the movie has not had
held and then um plenty of it is
handheld but it's never a distracting
framing device I thought this is a very
well composed movie I totally think Todd
Phillips deserves
I think much praise and recognition he
definitely yes because intone is a
constant thing I hear directors
especially once word was funny the first
person I really heard honing on that was
patty Jenkins hi I had for a Wonder
Woman and then top hooks up for sure
that ones who are like redefine yeah
tone is very important I do agree that
opening shots opening scenes may gigas
the difference I think from writing
perspective and like as a whole the
openings can make the biggest of differ
tunity to sweep people literally off
their feet and into your yeah yeah and
that's that's hard to do it really
smooth opening yeah
we broke it down and her spoiler talk
like we talked a lot about the opening
specifically so it's cool to hear him
say it and be like hey I got a lot of
that somatically right I think a lot of
us did put it but that's the whole point
of a good four great director hone in on
it yeah yeah we're not watching this we
do right it's not watch the credits not
to me like anything the thing I picked
up most on was things in the direction
of what he chose to put in frame yes how
to frames and I did not pick up on
yeah successfully communicated tonal
aspects yeah yeah the attention to bring
the 1970s the life I thought was great
like beyond aesthetic design and tonal
design even using the he's talking about
when the four guys are running on the
story oh yeah and you have that that
depth of field where that's like really
limited to them and yeah everything else
out of focus because it's such a brief
shot but it's an important and that's
the thing about all filmmaking is
especially with directors like this is
most of the time that you'll get these
shots that only lasts a few seconds that
if you slow it down or the director and
everyone involved is like that's a
beautiful shot most of us will just move
on to the next thing
when it was when it was one of those
moments to where as he was breaking it
down I put it together right before he
said it where it's like oh no wonder
they must have shot all of these from
like obscure vantage points where
they're trying to hide a camera so no
wonder it's a really long time really
chaotic shot and yeah in a movie like
this it does serve to put you in that
time in place and it reminds you that
even if it's not for everything it is a
very useful technique yeah because
everything was about communicating the
emotion and I thought that was great
there was no shot in this movie that I
felt was about you know looking cool
yeah looking slick even there's nobody
seemed unconcerned with that absolutely
I'll finish it is like cuz like the big
shot that he's talking about where you
see Arthur always talk about how some of
the buildings in the background are CGI
and then Arthur's alone like kind of
like a Waldo shot yeah you see like the
chaoticness of Gotham at this time of
day and then you got this this clown
trying to entertain but no one's paying
attention and beautiful stuff I already
loved the hell out of this book and it's
already like elevated my appreciate like
was so much more at one of these forever
I can I can watch him talk about
everything actually yeah dude there's a
six-hour cut of this video
released the phillips cut really where
it's just him watching the movie and
breaking it down for you
I reject nation well what did you think
of this video the tufflips talks about
what was the main takeaway you had
everything we said that you like do you
like us so we direct the next Joker
movie I think we should I call it Joker
V Batman dawn of sequels dawn of Studio
do you guys can subscribe to the reel
rejects click that notification belly
you can check us on patreon we got a
bunch of goodies and Niraj thanks for
requesting this dude and the Raj as I
mentioned recently it's also [ __ ] ton of
weight and he told me he recently went
to a lucha match for the first time and
to participate to be a luchador that's
what I was going to segue into that you
should not be a viewer you should be
competing dude if you are losing weight
getting fit getting cut if there's one
thing I know
ladies love we can actually ID yeah pure
testosterone acting out of more today if
I had the body for lucha I would be down
across I would be wherever lucha happens
to do it I hear they're all very
mentally stable and I think you ought to
compete one day and I guarantee you all
your stress will be relieved in the ring
verily have my word